what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation this day is turning out to
be more eventful than d23 itself John how are you
I am super excited how are you sir super excited
the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 official
trailer has arrived if you haven't seen our
reaction to the holiday special that's up here
on this channel also please leave a like thirdly
thank you to all who have shown your support by
checking out our merch at shopzeroedition.com
get beatings like this to show your member of
the reject Nation citizen King exclusive we got
all kinds of cool things over there anywho it's a
good Christmas present that's what I'll say to us
we were gone for quite a while oh wow
new suits no matter what happens next
Galaxy still needs its Guardians
that's an upgrade yeah we come in peace
seriously dude oh hey dodgeball
don't forget
baby rocking
like the gorillas our whole lives
whoa Pete I'm done running
I'll rock it there is
there yeah
damn we'll all fly away together oh one last time
oh dang oh it doesn't stop
we are Groot we are Groot that is so much
more emotional that I was expecting don't
kill anyone who gets in our way no not
kill anyone kill a few people kill no
people kill one guy one stupid guy who no
one loves now you're just making it sad
wow especially after getting that holiday special
the last time we checked in with the Guardians to
be getting a trailer like that which just looks
insanely heavy oh yeah and full of all kinds of
emotional weight throughout I mean it really looks
like it's gonna be Rockets movie though I mean
even in this trailer as much as we're cutting
around and everyone as excited as it is to get
you know Adam Warlock into the phrase exciting as
it is to get high evolutionary into the mix which
obviously is going to be tied into Rocket Raccoon
story man Rocket's just like like would they have
that one image there of quill just like looking
over something and screaming it looked like he
was in the lab and I'm like is that Rocket's body
that he's like letting out that painful anguish
yell at you know yeah this looks like it's going
to be very painful and you know obviously haven't
seen the holiday special slight spoilers here
they've revealed that mantis and and Peter Quill
are indeed siblings actually both um children of
ego getting that kind of family thread tying into
here as well and then the Guardians means so much
about abandon Misfits who are like family and then
this heartbreak like this just looks so emotional
and ethereal that other flavor of James gun like
if you hop into like a show of James Gunn first
few episodes of the Season would be like Guardians
volume one and two and this would be like the
final stretch yeah it feels that way you know
like oh this one gets like really serious right
now yeah absolutely and I I'm really excited to
see what that makes of the tone and I think it's
no secret that you and I didn't absolutely love
the more sort of comedic and boisterous qualities
that the second movie had but I feel like this is
really cool because it incorporates obviously the
humor that we know and love from the guardians
but it does look so much more sort of impactful
and affecting and like it's going to be a finite
you know ending of at least this chapter in what
the Guardians of the Galaxy means to the MCU and
you had to see so many moments especially like I
almost wonder if the high evolutionary is using
some element of Peter's you know Celestial DNA
to you know do some kind of horrific experiment
or whatever it might be but you really get this
sense that sacrifices will be made there will
be loss and the family I'm mean that he said like
this is the last time we will see this Guardians
team together this way and I believe that you know
like you get that sense even off of this trailer
and I think that's really a beautiful opportunity
for James Gunn to come back and to perhaps put his
definitive stamp it's like he helped reinvent you
know what the MCU could be with the first movie A
lot of people love the spirit of the second movie
but this looks like it can make a huge impact and
really showcase James Gunn's more mature and
more dramatic filmmaking chops as well because
you know family is a convergence of warmth and
humor and and you know spirits but also you know
it's it's hard and there are times where families
are tested and I feel like that's absolutely what
this is going to be I think they're gonna have
to be bringing back some things from the first
couple of gardens movies I imagine that with
Aisha at the end of Guardians post-credits scene
of part two tied into Adam Warlock in some way
since she's the one who introduced him the high
evolutionary the little glimpses we got this dude
does look Sinister and even though he had like a
funny Comic-Con entrance sorry you got to show up
in costume and stuff he does look Sinister and I
mean they all look like they're going through just
hell in this trailer because even though Drax is
like funny and stuff there are moments here where
he it's just the Peril and the pain just seems so
present also with Gamora this Gamora you know like
where does she belong and she's obviously going to
be linking up with them will her and Peter fall
in love like this feels like there's gonna be so
many heartbreaking elements to it also or perhaps
a sense of melancholic Unity by the end yeah which
is like the main flavor yet you might want out of
a film like this you know absolutely but the space
sequences also just look beautiful there are parts
of it that remind me of what I've heard about 2001
A Space Odyssey yeah and also a little bit of JJ
from Star Trek in a way sure yeah and I love that
you also have that aspect of James Gunn's you
know Vision on display this very colorful very
much like a cartoon or a comic but it literally
there is a recent gorillas music video where they
are all like on the moon and get those different
colored spacesuits and it looks almost exactly
like that to me but I love that that even with
this heavier installment we're still getting
these really imaginative new looking you know
colorful popping visuals yeah and it's cool you
know if the holiday special didn't come out I
wouldn't be as excited for every little moment
I've seen a mantis yeah it's kind of crazy like
that the holiday special really did something for
me when it comes to mantis so every time I see
something special or like her little emotional
beats that you see of her in this trailer actually
hit that much more because of the fact that she
was the main character in the holiday special
and we got to really understand her with that
much more depth everything about this trailer was
really cool and said I was surprised by it and of
course the we are Groot him and Peter firing
the guns together the action's probably gonna
be James Gunn's best out of this Trilogy easily
I wonder how much you're gonna let him let loose
with going all out because damn this like you
just skim this if you just skim this without
music you just or audio these visuals uh they
hit on a whole different kind of level because
they really do serious ass [__] you know yeah
and that's kind of what I'm getting at here is
this I I I'm not I wasn't prepared for that but
yeah and also new space creatures and stuff like
that but uh here we are Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. it all comes to a close here guys what did
you think about this trailer please leave your
thoughts down below and uh listens for the pain
flat door and buddy I know that uh Black Panther
wakanda forever did not quite hit the mark for
you in the way you were hoping but this trailer
shows me that this could do something special I
hope this one delivers for you dude the flip
trailer regardless flev I want to say thank
you for all the sweet things you've been saying
to us throughout the months especially I made a
post on patreon last month where you said some
of the kindest things ever so those things are
really take to heart and you are part of the
reject Nation family in every single way so dude
I hope you have an amazing Christmas a happy
holidays and you know make some awesome 2023
resolutions because you've got some goals
to accomplish and we have faith that with
someone with a spirit like yours you're able
to do it dudes love you fluffy flop fluffle